hey guys we are here with a live video
and we're here with Logan and he came to
Virginia today so I've decided to do a
video we did a video on cancer okay cuz
he had cancer he had surgery he had
we're gonna show him the skull injury
yeah right through there this is like
two and a half years ago yeah so we did
the video and I completely forgot one
little piece of the puzzle that I'm
gonna do right now and you can you can
basically learn from this and apply it
if you want it's a technique it's an
acupressure technique and now before I
get into this I know a lot of you guys
just saw the video that I just did on
the water you know you doing drinking
more water it creates more harm than
good and there's been a I stirred up a
hornet's nest okay cuz everyone's like
wait a second I was tall told that I
need to drink more water bla bla bla
well here's the thing you're the and I'm
just gonna touch on this and we're gonna
go right to the video your body is not
98% water it's actually 98% fluid
okay so there's electrolytes there's all
this fluid so when you drink water
without electrolytes you're actually
diluting the electrolytes
I'm not against drinking enough water to
prevent kidney stones or dehydration
well what I am against is drinking
massive ones that want quantities of
water while you're exercising doing a
marathon depleting your electrolytes and
then having you dropped at a heart
attack there's just something about that
I don't think it's a good idea but
that's just me so what I'm gonna
recommend is that you drink when you're
thirsty so people are saying well how
much did I drink drink when you're
thirsty okay your body will tell you
then you say well what if I'm not paying
attention we'll just pay attention and
then drink when you're thirsty
oh I've Kitty stuff okay drink more
water okay but just don't like drink
massive amounts without the electrolytes
okay good getting back to this video he
he had surgery two and a half years ago
and what happens now is he's not it's
not getting a high quality sleep correct
so we're gonna get him to sleep like a
baby tonight
now I'm gonna do some acupressure you
can do this on your friends and
neighbors and relatives and it's very
therapeutic and it's basically for
anyone who had any head injuries or head
surgeries so here's what you do it's
really simple okay so if we look at this
side here oh by the way going back six
years previous
he had basketball injuries someone
stepped on his head yeah okay on the
left side right on your left side yeah
right there
so someone actually smashed this side of
his head and it just so happens when the
doctor looked at he said the tumors
growing for six years and I have found
this interesting connection between old
injuries and tumors like it seems to
grow where you had an old injury so
something triggered it
not to mention cell phone but the thing
is that that could explain why certain
people have cancer in certain parts of
the body that being said what we want to
do with this technique is actually do
acupressure on the mirror image side
okay we're gonna do on the opposite side
which is gonna be on this side right
here and also I'll probably do it on
because he has two little incisions or
two little scars right here and then I
found out when he was like I think five
years old or two years old yeah right
three four three or four he was he felt
upside down on his head another injury
and did you break a bone broke my neck
see one of our guys the first bird of
reppin the neck and okay so we got our
vertebrae here you can see here's here
back of the skull this is c1 right there
the top one that's the called the atlas
and that thing ninety percent of all
your motion occurs at that level so turn
turn your head back before tell me if
you have any restriction in your in your
neck anything there's no worse tricky
part behind here cracks cracking you
feel it okay so anyway he had a lot of
injury to his neck and skull so I'm
gonna show you what to do what you do is
you massage the opposite side so let me
just take a look
so that's right around here right so
they actually took the skull off right
they yeah okay so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna press on the opposite mirror
image side and I'm just gonna show you
I'm just massaging now the way that you
know you get the right spot is it's
gonna be very tender like really tender
so you tell me where the tender is a
tenderness is let me see okay so tell me
if it's anywhere through here I close
here or here but sir they're right there
okay once you find the tenderness you
just work it out because when you
actually have a surgery or injury it can
ship the plates in the head there's
actually joints in your skull sutures
are called how about through here yes
okay oh yeah yeah so it's always gonna
be tender more tender on the opposite
side and I'm just gonna massage this for
about an hour no I'm just kidding Yeah
right there huh yeah just feels really
tight yeah and this is on the good side
uh-huh it's really wild it'll always be
20 tender on the opposite side
so we're on Instagram we're on YouTube
but I don't seem happen to see um it
says live but I don't know I don't know
why the I think maybe I had the chat on
off but I can't see any comments how
about this is any of this tender yeah
right there right yeah
I try to get a job as an interrogator
but I press too hard so I became a
chiropractor right through there yeah
mm-hmm good morning
so I'm just showing you guys some my
thumb I'm just pressing on the exact
place that he had incision on the
opposite side okay so now I'm just going
to kind of push it upward the thing you
what you don't want to do is press on
the side where we had the incision so
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take my thumb I'm going to press up on
this suture suture is a joint between
the skulls feel that
and just when you do this you just have
to make sure that you don't mess up the
hair valuable that's the most important
thing oh yeah
yeah it'll actually definitely help him
sleep tonight you'll you'll be sleeping
like a baby
of course babies are up all that crying
I mean you you know they put him out
when they cut the skull but still the
body retains memory
yeah and they they woke me up for a few
hours - oh they did
yeah cause awake for towards the middle
of it and they would ask me questions oh
my gosh
cuz that was that was to see like am I
gonna lose my speaking and hearing or
not uh you know that's how he knew when
he was going in to remove it yeah he
knew that if I couldn't speak or hear
then he had been stopped and you know
cut off the you know not remove the
whole tumor that's quite incredible now
one little secret okay so what we want
to do if the injuries on this side we
want to press into the injury so I can
also press down this way
okay and then also on the eyebrow
because he actually someone stepped on
his head he's playing basketball six
years previous so I'm right here I'm
just gonna press on here tell me when
it's tender here here here yep okay just
doing the opposite side and kind of
covering up I'm doing this but let's see
if I can just do it like this I'm not
flipping you off right through in here
and said where it is yeah okay mm-hm
and this is on the good side oh yeah
those right there so we just have to
make sure the next time someone steps on
your head you have to duck and dodge
faster so they don't actually land on
the skull okay now you should feel like
your heads a little bit lighter sleep it
really relaxes especially old injuries
so now what we're gonna do
he had a compression injury when he was
three so I'm going to kind of like I'm
gonna lift up on the skull and like
here's the back of his skull right see
this thing I'm gonna lift up right here
and stretch all of this to kind of like
undo the compression that he had and I
think that my stress I would say sits
right here that's what I've noticed yep
it's feel good or bad yeah that's good
so I'm tractioning the connection
between the skull and the first vertebra
which he fractured
oh yeah it's like cement
right there yeah
how's it certain to feel Wow
yeah I feel I feel lighter oh my gosh
and we're basically removing a lot of
the stored energy that gets stuck after
injuries in tension and trauma and it
should just like you should have more
space on your head yeah let me see if
there's anything else you ever have any
sore throats no no okay and then you
just tilt your head back look up too
soon back okay sometimes you can have
compression right through there yeah
just to make sure it's all cleared out
good this sounds good okay so now we
have a video of how to do this to your
friends and neighbors right just go up
to your neighbor and say oh yeah I have
a seat let me do work on you but work on
the opposite press into the injury you
can lift up on the skull so do you feel
more relaxed now I feel I feel like I
was a little unflavored and now I feel
totally just no stress no tension in the
body or like anywhere it's amazing so I
got just like foam rolled my whole my
whole upper body up here yeah I know
that's why he was he actually left my
office I says hold on and come back we
forgot one thing because this is going
to help you sleep and it's just kind of
this is how you should feel normally